hi guys it's silver and again and I've
got a tutorial on advanced terrain
editing and that sounds very interesting
but it's actually a trick that not many
people use but it's actually pretty
useful and that is take a non blending
texture like this one as you can see it
doesn't blend in there with the grass if
you take this texture for example you
could see this little blending andreen
on here and you don't want that I always
use this texture because as you can see
every tile represents the tile of the
grits so that's very handy now what
you're going to do is you're going to
make a chessboard pattern say for
example I want some rough grass then I'm
just going to play some Bach textures in
here oops
I'm not supposed to do that's anyway you
get the point of it let's forget about
that last bit right now it's not really
important and then you're going to fill
all the rest in with normal grass and as
you can see now you've got a somewhat
rougher grass rock ish texture that's a
lot different than all of the grass
textures in game so that's nice but that
isn't the only variations there well the
variations are limitless
you've got a lot of options when it
comes to this honestly one of the
options that are also like is for
example when you've got this dry coast
in a Mediterranean climate for example
you take this little soil kind of
texture and put it all over the place
and then you take this white sand over
here and the somewhat lighter sign over
there and you're just going to fill in
the rest of the little tiles and as you
can see it gets a somewhat in between
texture that's a little bit sand ish but
still has that dry texture from the soil
so that's really nice now you can
honestly blend all of these things
together I would really recommend to try
experimenting with this try different
textures and maybe you'll find something
new but basically this isn't the only
technique you can use for this there are
two other techniques I haven't seen many
people use these before but I like using
them I'm just going to create a big
square over here for the sake of the
tutorial and I'm going to remove these
because I'm perfect
and first of all we've got the I have no
idea what this technique is called
technique and I can't come up with the
name but it basically goes like this you
just put something down every other tile
and then you're going to fill the rest
in with grass for example because I want
some dark ross now this still blends in
but the grass for example blends in more
than the dark of the asphalt texture so
as you can see what you get is grass but
just a little bit more dark than you use
your in-game grass so if you want for
example a forest or a little bit more
mossy kind of texture and this is this
is really good
but there is also a variation on this
technique and it starts out the same and
for the safety tutorial I'm going to use
the same texture but say for example you
want dots but with a little bit of
earthy soil mixed in well mix basically
yeah just put that down in between so
you get a chessboard pattern like this
and then fill the rest in the texture
that you like and then as you can see
you get the same kind of idea a little
bit darker grass but it's a bit little
bit brownish it's almost like it's a
construction site or something or it's
been taken over by nature or something
like that's I have no idea but once
again that's one that's one of the
limitless options I mean you can try
countless of things with that and if
you're a smart person and you've already
seen this coming then you've seen this
coming because you see next time never
mind
and yeah that's there's of course
there's a there's a fourth way you can
do this and yeah you must have seen it
coming start out the same way that we
just started out I'm just going to make
some random textures here this one looks
nice so we're gonna put this out beware
and
now we are going to mix it with this
texture yes
oops I'm going to replace that okay now
so far so good and now comes the little
bit harder parts where you have to
concentrate to get it right we're going
to take this texture and we're going to
fill on every other diagonal tile like
this yeah that's good
this requires some concentration because
you don't want to miss anything so
that's that's all good and let's say for
example we want some sand with this
because we're going to mix everything
together then you get an even more
complex texture and now this isn't the
nicest of textures because I've mixed
some weird things so you get a pretty
weird texture but this is this is the
fourth option and if you can really make
some very well mixing textures I've
rarely seen people do that but
especially with the grass it's possible
then this can give you limitless options
basically so that's it for advanced
texturing I'm just going to show you a
few textures that I really like with
these tricks
all right this for example is arguably
the best most texture in the game it's
made by mixing the asphalt texture with
this little bit lighter greener ish
green than the usual grass and yeah
that's when you get this and this is
very useful for magical forests or just
well dense forests in general all right
this is the somewhat greyish asphalt
texture as I like to call it I've used
this one in my coaster ileus shout-out
to those who still remember at least by
the way and it's a little bit more light
and grayish than the in-game asphalt
which is a little bit too dark for my
taste and this is this is great for
paths for example and it's made by
mixing this dark asphalt actually with
this very light texture you see over
here and that's where you get this now
the last one is what I'd like to call
the in-between sand you mix this darker
sand with this dune sands
and the reason why I like to do that is
because this dune sands is way too light
and if you turn on bloom it's just going
to kill your eyes and yeah it's nice to
mix it with with this dark scent like
this and yeah you still have that
dooney's windy sand texture but it's a
little bit darker and that's nice
alright so as an example I want to give
my coaster called
all for I've used this I've used few of
these tricks all over the place as you
can see these aren't the normal in-game
textures I've used a lot of rock
textures and mixing them with grass
textures as you can see and also using
sand textures here and there
these are these little yellow brownish
spots and altogether it looks pretty
nice I think so this is the way you can
use these techniques and I hope you
learned something from this tutorial so
thanks for watching